jonathan pagio did i get that right
yes that's great good that's cool that's
a cool way of saying it australians are
really great at butchering names that
should sound
lovely like that like peggy peggy oh or
something it's hard to say my name in
english because
we don't usually the ajo is not an
english pronunciation
like the normal way would be to say pat
joe or something like that
it's just not it's a it's a very french
way of saying a french name
french is my first language so okay yeah
that's awesome well it's really lovely
to meet you i don't know how we first
connected somebody told me i should
interview you and then i
i looked i looked you up and i really
enjoyed you know the things you had to
say and
i i go to an eastern catholic church and
so you know all that you were doing with
icons i found super intriguing so it's
really nice to finally touch base
yeah same i've had several people in my
let's say people following me or said
you know you know matt fred what he's
doing and so
i looked into what you're doing so i was
happy that you connected with me and i
thought
i think you connected with me in march
and then with the
pandemic and everything things just kind
of we didn't we didn't follow through
and then recently someone said again
you know you need to to contact him and
i said i think i remember an email by
him
so i went in and i said yeah perfect
let's do this that's right
so i mean it's hard for me to kind of
gauge reality at this point
i'm about to move to steubenville ohio
but right now i'm in georgia
and i don't know if i've just drunk the
kool-aid or what but like
any kind of lockdown any kind of
mandatory whatever just like
really rubs me the wrong way meanwhile
my family in australia had this six day
lockdown they weren't allowed to walk
their dog
i don't see the reason anyway so it
really bothers me and i've seen a few
things
uh up in canada where these police have
broken into a person's house gestapo
style and
i find it super troubling i just was
interested what you thought
yeah it's very i find it very troubling
as well we just have they've started a
new lockdown now which is
uh with a apm curfew you know you're not
allowed to
walk with other people not allowed to i
think they said if if
someone is living alone one person is
allowed to go visit them or something
like that
frigging generous yeah exactly so it
really pisses me off i
like who the hell are these people to
tell us
this kind of stuff and i think up in
canada i'm how old do i look
i'm cleaning my glasses i'm just old and
curmudgeonly everything pisses me off
it's not just canada
um you know i i've heard i've got some
friends up in canada and they say
they're kind of encouraged to snitch on
their neighbors if they have large
gatherings
what a great way to destroy the sort of
social fabric
well that's what it feels like what it
feels like is is
a difficulty it's there's a kind of
materialism which is seeped in
you know where we think that the
integrity of the body is the only thing
that matters
you know and so it's it's in line with a
kind of insipid materialism that we live
with
and then there's a kind of objective
sense where they
feel like because we're talking about
medical therefore
there's no opinion to be had there's no
there's no morality involved it's just
we're gonna save lives and we're gonna
do anything we can
for people to stop dying uh and so
they feel people just accept it and also
we've we've accepted the role of the
state as this
totalizing thing in our in our lives
it's something which has been seeping in
you know
after world war ii it just started to
grow and grow and grow and grow and now
everybody has just accepted it and we
think that basically the state can tell
us
what to do they basically manage our
identities they manage
they're allowed to tell religious groups
if they can meet or not and
you know and they all do it for our our
good and so it's a very
it's a strange situation that we've
we've kind of seeped into a
authoritarian state and people tell me
it's for a good reason and i
and maybe i don't know but it's
authorian states have always said it's
for a good reason
you wouldn't install authoritarianism
for a bad reason it's always
we're doing it for your good right we're
doing it to help you so
yeah it's a frightening moment yeah yeah
yeah gosh i i just saw recently these
greek orthodox christians uh were like
you know meeting regardless of the uh
for epiphany regardless of the covert
laws which i thought was just super
badass i was pumped about that
um yeah there's just part of me this is
like we've almost like totally given
them this control we've allowed it so
like
it's times like this that make me look
at my like conservative conspiracy
theory friends i'm like
tell me what you were saying again
because it's yeah
it definitely feels like there's some at
least
agreement among nations because they're
all using the same words they're all
using
the same language you know we've heard
this build built back better
used by biden and then trudeau and then
you know boris uh in england and so it's
like everybody's using the same language
and so it's even though you don't
necessarily need to think of a top-down
conspiracy
there's at least a strange agreement
about what it is we're doing and
and uh and the sacrifices we're willing
to make in order to get there
and i think that's what no one talks
about is is that we we've
we have this goal and we think they they
talk as if
we're willing to sacrifice everything to
get to this goal
and we don't want to talk about the cost
in terms of everything else mental
health
society uh the the cohesion of groups
you know the even the abandonment of the
elderly like we've completely
in quebec like the elderly have been
completely abandoned and we do it for
them like we're
we're doing it for their good but we're
not allowed to visit them they're not
allowed to see anybody
they're i know some people whose uh
uncles parents are in an apartment and
they haven't
left for months and they're not allowed
to even walk out on their balcony
and so it's insane did you see that
parlor just got shut down because
amazon kicked them off their servers and
app do you know what parlor is
yes yes yeah no that's trying to look it
up it doesn't exist anymore no it
doesn't exist it's been nuked
this is ridiculous yep i always tell you
there's a there's a serious lockdown on
information
and it all it fits together even if it
doesn't even if it's not
whether it's planned or not it fits
together because as we're at home
and we encounter the world only through
the internet
then that becomes the frame for reality
yeah so
if you're able to now control that frame
then you have a control over what
reality is and you can tell people
what's happening
and they have no way to know besides
yeah accessing reality through like i
get the argument when someone says these
are private companies they can do what
they want but as you say
when twitter and facebook and instagram
have become the town square
and then you say and you are not allowed
to come um
and then so you know it does really feel
like you're canceling free speech
and it doesn't feel like a breach of the
first amendment even though i know
technically it isn't
but not only you're not allowed to come
to the town square but we're gonna shut
down
any other town square that you try to
open so it's not just that i know it's
like can we go meet over here in chat
no that's band too this is insane i um
i i'm just sort of waiting i was talking
to my wife today and i'm like okay i
just hit a hundred thousand subscribers
on youtube i'm excited
cancel it like come at me i just i just
can't wait like so here we go maybe this
would get me kicked off
if you are a if you are a catholic or an
orthodox out there
go find a priest who will flout the
covert rules
to bring you eucharist uh if this thing
gets locked down i've already found some
priests like absolutely he's like we're
going to print out mapquest directions
we won't even let have people use google
we're going to meet in a parishioner's
home
and you'll receive eucharist bring it
well it's
it seems like i mean i think that that's
the kind of thing that's been happening
uh just privately i would say and i know
that
some churches are being stricter in
terms of the the
the guidelines and some are being at
least secretly more
permissive and so it's hard because
we're also called as christians to
to obey the rule of the state we know we
we try to not
be to reveal the rule for no reason of
course
if the law is reasonable we should obey
it
it's a tough situation it's a very
difficult it's a very difficult place
that we are in right now that's for sure
and it's hard to know what is the right
thing what is the right thing
no it's totally you're exactly right i
mean everyone with a bloody youtube
channel thinks they're an expert
exhibit a and i know nothing i know
nothing except it's going to be left
alone to worship god and
be with my friends and family but so i'm
fully you know fully admitting that i
don't know what i'm talking about in
many respects
and i know we're all we're all listening
to people who know what they're talking
about either
and then just whoever feels the most
appealing to us we i don't know
it's crazy all right um i want to talk
to you about icons
it's like it's hard to talk about
anything besides what's happening and i
totally
i totally understand that because like
that's immigration
has been so crazy like the imagery of
the
of the capital takeover was so mad like
it was one of the
maddest things that i've seen the
imagery of that shaman with like the
horns
you know walking through the capitol
with like face paint on
feels like we're in a video game that's
what it feels like
yeah it was gross for sure how did how
did canadians sort of respond to it
i don't know i don't i know how i
responded so you haven't
exactly and i don't watch the news
because i'm tired of the propaganda so
it's hard to even know it's hard to get
like i can't watch cbc because i
want to wrench if i try to watch cbc
here and
and it's difficult to find alternative
it's a little harder to find with the
alternative media
in canada than you know than in the us
yeah and we'll see how long they're
around for
but but honestly though like i was
thinking this the other day i was
driving in my car and i was listening to
some political talk show and i just
thought
this is not good for me at this point
like i could be listening to like
bulgarian orthodox chant or
soothing jazz or something but not
this like i know i would be healthier if
i just unplugged
um that's not to say that we shouldn't
kind of keep abreast of these issues and
have an idea of what's going on but
at some point it's like how much
politics can i take in
and we all we've all heard the stories
of those you know fathers and
grandmothers who
have been told by the doctor you need to
stop watching fox news you know whatever
so i mean this kind of comes to the
point about talking about iconography
and religious things like
for you as an as an artist not wanting
to go insane
i mean what kind of suggestions you have
for for christians like me and
others yeah well it's the same i think
that i have to apply my rules to myself
one of the things i've been doing now
you know for the for a little while is i
make sure that
when i get up in the morning i pray
before i do
anything else like before i pick up my
phone and before i look at my
notifications if
any of that i tried to pray before that
can i ask you what you pray
i just pray the morning prayers the
orthodox morning prayers and then i
i tried to do a little bit of the jesus
prayer
you know which is these days is not
super successful because we're so
we're so like our minds are so taken up
that it you know i find myself
wandering in my thoughts while i'm doing
the jesus prayer so
hopefully that will get better but i
agree i've had the same
since christmas i've kind of decided to
to break away a little bit and not get
not listen to too many political
podcasts not
be too and try to get the bare minimum
to at least know what's happening
but not get involved in the commentary
and and the infighting
but then now recently because it's the
social media world that is being
affected itself because
i mean i think it's the same for you in
a way this is my
part of my job you know it's like when
the youtube videos start to get
uh shadow banned and there's start to be
warning on your youtube videos
then that's affecting me so i need to
it's harder to to uh
to stay neutral and to to to break off
from that
so at least you have a respectable skill
like art and carving i just yell about
things i don't understand
yeah i can luckily i can fall back i'm
screwed yes
that is true and i try like i've been
trying to also do that
uh i've been doing better like get up in
the morning pray
go carve for like three hours and then
after that get into emails and stuff
that way i'm not as frantic as i am when
i start right away on the
on the emails and the and the social
media stuff you're such a talented guy
because i mean
i've been looking at your uh i'm going
to pull it up right now
and uh i'm going to show people some of
your carvings it's
absolutely incredible did you ever kind
of um
you know as i say write icons or is it
just has it been carving is that
considered writing i don't understand
well i i kind of joke because the word
to write in uh
in greek is actually uh it means to
incise
and so i think that i win when i say i
carve icons that i
you know that i just carved them but the
writing icons things is complex i don't
like to use that term
i just i carve i carve icons uh it's
kind of a marginal art let's say
in the in the orthodox tradition but it
is uh
it's it is legitimate and there are icon
carvings you know from the beginning
all the way until recently it's being
revived
kind of like icon painting was revived
in the mid 20th century and so
i think that right now icon carving is
also being revived by a few people
myself included and and then a few
carvers all over the world
yeah i'm showing folks uh right now what
it looks like
it's amazing i mean when did you get
into this well when i was i grew up uh
baptist protestant and then when i was
in college i studied painting
but i was really struggling to join my
theology which i wanted to take
seriously
and the art making it feel like it just
didn't jive together
so all my art in college was about image
making and the problem of image making
as a protestant
and in the western tradition and so it
just became like this weird
self-referential thing which is great
for post-modern art but it's not good
for your spiritual health
and so i and that's one of the things
that kind of pushed me towards
uh becoming orthodox is as i discovered
at first medieval art
and fell in love with the let's say
internal language of the church that the
church had developed this beautiful
uh sacred visual language that you could
find all over christendom you know uh
from syria to spain basically and so
i i discovered this and at first i was
kind of sad because i thought it was
gone and that it wasn't
accessible anymore but then when i
discovered iconography and how it was
still alive in the orthodox church it
was one of the things that led me to uh
to convert and so i wanted to paint
icons which is what most people want to
do
but at that time it was a in 2001 2002
um icon painters were very difficult to
access it was hard to find someone to
teach you
and act just just happenstance my
parents cut down a tree in their yard
and they said you want to
you want to have that go with this and i
thought i'm going to make a blessing
cross and so
that was it and that was the catechumen
at the time and then that's kind of what
started it all
i see i'm showing people right now these
kind of crucifix medallions
that you've put together as well that's
amazing what's that made out of it looks
like stone
so a lot of yeah one of the things that
i'm carving is
a stea steeatite so it's kind of a kind
of soapstone okay
um it's an old tradition from the old
byzantine tradition which kind of
went away when constantinople fell but
i'm trying to revive that because we
don't really have access to carving
ivory so much anymore it's
very difficult and so the steotite or
the stone is a way to
to kind of regain a certain look of
ivory and miniature and stuff
um and so it's the thing i really like
the car the most actually i'm looking at
this
seed of wisdom statue of our of our
blessed mother and our lord that is
just beautiful those were those were
someone a few catholic patrons have
asked me to make statues and
statuary isn't usual in the orthodox
tradition
it's hard to fully know exactly why it
has something to do with iconoclasm and
it's not sure exactly why statuary
didn't develop so much in the
in the east but um so when i i've had
some catholic patrons asking me to
to make statues and i i said i'll do it
if you accept that i try to kind of
integrate
it's kind of eastern iconographic
language in the statue and so it was an
interesting little game to play between
the statue and this
the the more let's say kind of medieval
but at the same time looking more
eastern
i i actually prefer it a lot more and
i've been thinking about why that is the
case you know i've been
going to a byzantine church now for
about six years um
and and i think it's i don't know what
it is but like here's how i
here here's how i explain it if somebody
took a photo of a beautiful woman
say dressed up like the theotokos i
wouldn't want to use that
um in in a you know while praying and i
think a lot of people would agree like
well yeah no like you don't want someone
who like looks like jenny down the road
um and and statues kind of have that
they they
i mean i know icons can look tacky if
they're not well
done i think statues have a better
likelihood of looking tacky
but i actually really like this of the
theotokos it's
it's kind of yeah it is a really
beautiful blend between east eastern
well
east and west i guess and if you you if
they look a little bit i tried to make
them look a little bit like the seed of
wisdom statuary that was popular in the
11th 12th century in the west as well
tried to find trying to recapture
you know the strength of the medieval
christian art
you know in a in a way that is
surprising at the same time
golly this is outstanding i'm just
clicking around and showing people
what they look like this one of our
blessed lord what does that mean in
greek i think it's greek
pantecrator is that that means the ruler
of all the lord of all
okay it's usually it's the image that
you find in the dome of the church for
example right
so it's like christ coming back at the
at the last judgment
gosh that's beautiful so as you had this
sort of um conversion if you want to the
orthodox church did you find
we i mean were you a serious baptist as
a child
yes i would say so i was very involved
in the youth groups and
you know i was kind of artistic and so
in my young adulthood i wrote a lot of
plays that were performed and kind of
toured around quebec you know
kind of event evangelical these big
evangelical type plays
so i was quite involved but i would it
was really at least
starting in my early 20s i would say
it became like a crisis really like a
major crisis in terms of the depth of uh
of the understanding but also the
problem of art um
and so that's really it was really kind
of my desire to find coherence that led
me
to to the to the orthodox church and
reading the church fathers
especially saint gregory of nisa um and
ultimately sam actually was the
confessor just like
that was it like i found really the
power of
the chris the christian worldview you
would say i felt like i discovered
i felt like i grown up in a world where
scientism was the world view and
christianity was like this weird
arbitrary revelation on top of it
whereas in discovering the church
fathers i discovered that
there's there's actually the shape of
the world is christian
and it's and the scripture actually
describes how the world
is like how it how it appears to us and
so
so i i really fell in love with that
that's beautiful um what's it been like
you know i know you've given some
lectures
on the same platform as people like
brett weinstein and jordan peterson
what's it like kind of discussing the
faith with people who may
or may not have a sort of more of a
secular mindset so they can appreciate
christianity for what it's given us but
they
they hold to a form of religion while
denying its power
yeah how's that been for you well it's
it's really been a surprise to be honest
because
before i met jordan peterson i was
mostly talking
inside right so i was talking about
christian symbolism to orthodoxy just
describing symbol symbolism and icons
and all this stuff so for years i ran
uh i was editing a journal called the
orthodox art journal
with other people um and so when jordan
kind of
threw me out there like he just kind of
threw me out into the public
i i encountered this secular crowd
and i tried to find ways to talk about
these things in a way that would be
understandable to secular people
yes and um and i've i mean i've been
really surprised to see that
you know there are a lot of people that
are staying on the secular side but i've
seen thousands of people
convert to christianity you know because
they're at the end of the nihilism
they're at the end of the
of the you know of this kind of weird
modern post-modern world that has been
given to them
and they're at the end of scientism as
well and so they
i i've seen a lot of people finally
understand at least under because one of
the problems we've had is that people
don't know what christianity's talking
about
you know a lot of a lot of times they
think it's just a kind of either it's a
kind of moralism or it's a kind of
arbitrary thing that if you don't
believe this you go to hell you know
that kind of nonsense
but when people start discovering that
it's actually discussing about this
talking about the structure of reality
and it's it's it's discussing how
reality
exists and how you need to engage with
reality uh
then then they they're surprised and
they're excited
that you know that this is still
available to them
yeah i think that's why jordan peterson
has been something of a gateway drug
into christianity for many people who
have abandoned the faith as kids he
kind of helped it become intelligible to
them in a way that they hadn't seen
before they
didn't realize it was that sophisticated
they just i don't know maybe thought it
had something to do with people who
denied evolution or something
well that's what i mean it's also
because of the it was kind of like the
new atheist moment which took over
in the popular culture you know and it
it
i don't know if it really took over in
the high intellectual spheres but it
definitely took over popular culture and
so you could have
a barely you know a somewhat intelligent
not super smart person
who had all the arguments laid out of
how how stupid religion is and how
all these contradictions in scripture
all this kind of stuff um
and how it doesn't fit with science but
then it's also because they were facing
a bunch of people
who are trying to read science into
genesis one yeah which is which is
so then these two things that face each
other
create this weird monstrous cultural
moment where we think that that's what
christians believe and then there are
actually some christians
who do think that yeah yeah and so
they've never encountered traditional
christianity before
these people yeah like you you you meet
a uh like a kind of debunker
and they talk about what most christians
believe and what they mean by most
christians
isn't most christians no i know it's
like it's like bible belt like this very
narrow
strip of and i find i find the most
the most i mean i know there are a lot
of very rational fantastic atheists i
get it but i think the most kind of
uh angry ones tend to be people who kind
of grew up in a fundamentalist home you
know they talk about how they grew up
christian and you're like oh that
doesn't
the kind of christianity you're
describing that you grew up with doesn't
actually sound like something i would
i would get on board with either yeah
and i mean most cr
the biggest christian group is catholic
in the world it's not
it's not this this fundamentalist group
and and catholicism
and then we have our own baggage right
with the craziness going on with all
this talk of pedophilia
and something the pope said about
something
that he may have been taken i mean so we
have our own way of
making christianity as a whole look
suspect yeah for sure i mean but that's
there's a difference between there's a
difference between
let's say the world view and the
doctrinal positions
which are something and then there are
the the kind of hypocrisy that you find
in
any any group any world and and you know
the kind of
the traitors that we find within the
hierarchical structure
you know and so i think that it's
important to be able to differentiate
that because
totally you know but it just gives
people an easy way to dismiss you like
if i wanted to dismiss you and then i
find out you're
you have hypocrites in the ranks easy
done i take the moral high ground i look
super great
i get to point to your immorality while
you've been trying to tell me to be
moral
you know and it's also it's easy because
because catholicism is such a
hierarchical structure you can point to
anybody
let's say anybody who has any authority
in the in the catholic church and say
that's catholic and yeah and you can
kind of incriminate the entire
ins this entire one of the biggest
institutions in the history of the world
probably the biggest
and incriminate the entire institution
because of
the fact that in that massive billion
people institution
there are some people who are using it
to their own perverse advantage
yeah i've often said you know if you're
looking for a perfect church
as soon as you join it it won't be like
suppose you were to have found it
you join it have you met you you're
disgusting it'll be awful
you know it's like it's yeah it's a lot
easier i guess if you've got a small
church down the road with 10 people to
try to keep you all together but when
you've got a billion plus
you're going to find hypocrites for sure
so one of one of the things i've done
in my work in the past is i've written
on the topic of pornography
and i've just found it really
interesting because it's definitely in
my history
it's something i'm tempted to from time
to time it's something i hate
um but i see the appeal of it i see how
it's kind of dragging people
into hell and into just a kind of boring
monotonous existence that they
don't want to be in but they feel they
have no no choice to be in
and i just wanted to chat with you about
that because i've had this idea which
isn't
terribly insightful but i think it is
accurate that pornography is like the
anti-icon
so if the icon sort of kind of brings us
into this larger reality
pornography does the opposite it
suppresses the personhood of the
performer
and sort of hollows her out or him out
as it were and leaves us with less than
what's there
yeah for sure i think there's a there's
a very good
it's very interesting to differentiate
let's say
the the idea of the icon and
the pornographic image because the
pornographic image is probably one of
the closest places where we could find
idolatry
today in terms of understanding what
ancient idols were
actually were which is that you create
an image or you create a
statue or an image and then that statue
becomes
a vehicle right it becomes a kind of
vehicle for some
demon like some spirit which which and
then
your encounter with that spirit is
is going to bring you something right
and it and pornography plays exactly
that role like
if you don't believe in incubate incubi
and succubi like
you're an idiot because that's exactly
what pornography is doing you're not
encountering the person right like you
said
they become hollowed out shells and they
become they become vehicles for
your passion and then ultimately
vehicles for
these you know let's say the way in
which your passion
that mode of being links together with
others is through a kind of
principality which is driving this whole
thing right because your passion isn't
driving
the industry of pornography but all the
passions of people
brought together and kind of as this
strange entity is what's driving this
thing
and and so the the pornographic image
becomes uh
becomes a place where that manifests
itself and it leads to a form of ecstasy
just like an idol like an idol would it
leaves
it can give you something like it gives
you some
momentary power or momentary ecstasy but
then like you said
because it is it is ultimately an idol
and it's not connected to
to god like an icon like an icon of like
when you meet a saint or you meet a holy
person that person is actually
revealing christ to you you know in the
opposite way then
pornography is breaking you away from
what
the true purpose of sexuality is what
the true purpose of love and
relationship is
um and so it's it's a it's a it really
is like you said a kind of anti-icon
yeah i mean if we think of like an icon
as i mean how would you define icon just
as
well the word is just means sacred image
like it's
the word icon just means image but it's
usually shorthand for
holy icon which is that you have a
sacred image
and a sacred image what it does is it
it reminds us first of all that god gave
us
renewed the image that he had placed in
us like renewed
the image of himself that he had put in
adam he renewed it in christ
and so the image of christ participates
in the way
that god reveals himself to us
and then the images of the saints they
also remind us and they help us
participate in
the fact that we're all together in this
this
church we're all together in this body
this cosmic body which is moving towards
the eschaton
um and so that's what icons do so
when you look at an icon of a saint
you're you're this it's present saying
the saint to you
but behind that it's also present saying
christ to you just like when you meet a
person
right that's kind of what i wanted to
get to you know i'm not sure if you've
heard of anthony eslin
or not but he's an excellent thinker he
has here's this quote of his he says we
sense that the human body is a precious
thing worthy of our reverence it is not
a tool
not an object of consumption like a
steak or a keg of beer
not an animate provider of pleasure it
is the outward expression
of a profound mystery that of another
human being
um and that's the evil of pornography
right there it uh
yeah we sh it's almost like it does what
death does in an analogous way it
separates body and soul and says i just
want this
oh you're exactly right it it it really
does it is a cleaving
it's like a cleaving of the person and
especially because
we already get a little bit of that just
in the technological image itself like
it's a dangerous game we play with these
screens it's already a danger but when
when that let's say when that danger
gets
brought to the extreme through this kind
of explicit
sexual act and also the kind of raw how
can i say this
the the nudity of shame you could say
you know where you you
have the permission to look at something
which is meant to be secret and meant to
be
holy like it's it's it's a
desacralization of something which is
meant to be
to be holy uh and so all of that brought
together
is exactly what you said it turns the
body into
pure meat pure object of desire um
and uh and it's not even the body it's
like an image it's like this
deincarnated
image like it's like this it is it's
almost like this
like i said it almost is like a like a
subtle body in the
in the very traditional sense which
manifests itself to you of these
these kind of demonic demonic forces oh
wow yeah
well let me let me just kind of unspool
here a little bit about my opinion on
the difference between pornography and
naked art
and then i would love you as an artist
to kind of help me kind of flesh this
out a little bit right because
um you know the word pornography entered
the english language in the mid 19th
century comes from two greek words which
means the
writing or drawing of the prostitutes
and it's clear
that the the kind of creators the
producers of pornography
mean for their product to interact with
the consumer in the way that a
prostitute would so pornography is
always meant to be a substitute for a
prostitute
you know i was just thinking like in
this crazy lockdown time that we're in
if you were a prostitute and had to work
online
what would that look like well it would
be pornography because
i think one of the primary maybe the
only notable difference between
pornography and prostitution is that
there is a camera
in the room um but with naked art
it's something altogether different you
know you don't find people
sort of being tempted to masturbate in
the sistine chapel you don't find them
going to some beautiful art museum
and and and finding that temptation and
yet you see
the body and all of its beauty it the
breasts and the genitals and
this is all lovely and it seems like
though you're being drawn into an
interior world
there's something going on there is a
complexity and interiority to the person
um whereas i mean i don't i i tend to be
not i'm not on the on this let's say i i
don't mind the fact that nudity exists
in the art but it's
it's definitely to me like when nudity
started to reintegrate
art let's say in the during the
renaissance and later it seemed to me
like it's a it was a
strange pagan move oh really because
if you if you read the if you read the
early councils when they they accepted
the images in the church and when you
read how the church fathers talk about
one of the reasons why icons look the
way they do is because
roman art was erotic roman art was
extremely erotic
and so what the christians did is they
took the roman forms
and they if you look at the figures
they're using roman tropes everything
about iconography is based on roman
tropes
the the you know the the fold the
clothing
every the poses even the contrapposto
all of this comes from roman statuary in
roman painting
but it was de-eroticized and so the
all the figures are covered and then the
contrapposto was adjusted slightly so
that it's not as sensual
so all of it there's like a and you can
read i think it was even
uh saint basil i'm not sure don't quote
me on that so one of the fathers talked
about
how you know the the images that are
represented in the church have to be
not to not to attract attention to your
desires like they need to be
they need to have a sobriety to them so
that you're not
tempted by them um and so i do think
that because
like in the sistine chapel you even the
sistine chapel now they've been restored
but
it didn't take long for the nuns to
paint thing vines over the
over the genitals which would remove now
they've been removed by john paul ii
which i thought was that's cool that we
disagree on this because i think that i
i think i disagree with you on that i
think that
i mean whatever we might say of
christian tradition and the fathers and
their opinions i mean
the argument that that one would make uh
would be that the body
can be portrayed in a way
that is decent and good or not and so
would your argument be that you actually
can't portray
the body through drawing or painting in
a way that
i think that i think that the best way
that i would understand that
is mostly that the body or the naked
body
is has two aspects to it there are two
nakednesses
you could say and those those were
related to the story in genesis
like one is the nudity in the garden and
it's the nudity
in uh the secret place where you're
you're in communion with god
and then that when at the fall that
nudity gets
turned into the nudity of shame and in
the outside of the garden then you
cover yourself and so i think that that
duality
remains the same and so i think there is
of course like you said
absolute dignity and beauty and power to
the human body but there's something
of the altar in that in that
that power there's something of the
sacredness of the body
which needs to be preserved and hidden
uh
for the moment of the bride and the
groom like for the
for the the encounter of the bride and
the groom in the hidden
chamber so that's kind of more of the
way that i
i understand it so your idea would be
that since the time of the fall
is no longer appropriate to depict the
body naked
well i would say that it's hard to
depict it naked
without the shame and so that's why
christ was
represented not fully naked on the cross
but let's say
as naked as possible and it was somewhat
scandalous even when it started
christ started to appear that way on the
cross christ was represented
fully clothed until like the early
let's say i didn't even know what the
first time the
i think it was in the 9th century around
the time of charlemagne
that christ started to appear as naked
on the cross or as almost naked
and i think that it was meant to
represent the nakedness of shame
it was meant to the nakedness or
a way in a way you could say joining the
nakedness of shame with the nakedness in
the garden in a very
strange very surprising way the way
christ unites
opposites and extremes together but but
that was one of the only places where
that where the kind of the body was
shown was when christ was dead on the
cross and
i would say that it's mostly that it has
to do with the secret it has to do with
a mystical reality which is still kept
you could you could say something like i
imagine that in paradise we'll all be
naked right like in in the kingdom maybe
or
clothing glory the way that we would be
wearing nike well we won't be wearing
nike that's for sure
or clothing glory the way that the the
the fathers talk about
the nakedness of the garden something
like that what's your opinion on those
beautiful breastfeeding madonna icons
i don't know i think i think that they
i think that they start out okay and
then they get more and more
disturbing you know and by disturbing do
you mean sensual like
leading to sexual definitely i think
that in the baroque period there is a
there's a there's a kind of sensuality
like you look at a reuben's painting and
it's just
it's just all it's very sensual i mean
the body what's he what's that cold
sorry i want to look it up rubens
so ruby i shouldn't look it up i guess
rubens
what would i type painting yeah ruben's
painting
yeah okay yeah no i see what you mean
how they become more sensual well
let's i don't want to put a pin in that
i don't want to keep fleshing that out
but just kind of back up a little bit
you know i suppose when we talk about um
you know pornography
you know you you could talk about it
from different angles right like there's
the one who produces the pornography
there is the one who
quote unquote performs in the
pornography then you have
the consumer right and i suppose
in fact i would say it's it is the case
that one can look at pornography and not
sin
uh because you know you we have these
sort of police officers who have to say
look at
images of child pornography in order to
identify
victims and catch these people or you
might have a mother say who
accidentally stumbles upon what a child
has been seeing
and and scrolls through to understand it
you know i would say that this
because of the intention of the viewer
watching pornography while it may always
be harmful to some degree
one isn't always culpable for it yeah
but but i
um and i suppose it's possible that
someone could look as you say upon these
reuben
paintings or even the icon of the
breastfeeding madonna and
feel lust uh and have their sexual
their sort of lower passion stirred up
um
but i've always thought i guess that you
know especially in regards to say the
icon or even the sistine chapel that the
problem wasn't with the
art it wasn't with depicting the body
which is good
it it's always been with the the the
person that there's a problem in the
heart if i am to look upon something
holy like the breastfeeding madonna icon
and feel lust so that's not a problem
with the depictions
it's the problems with with me but no i
think you're i think you're on to
i think you're on to the you're right in
the in an absolute sense
but i i i still nonetheless think that
it's a dangerous
because at the very least like let's say
one says
you can depict the body in a responsible
way which i'm not
you it sounds like you're leaning
towards not necessarily after the after
the garden right but it but even if that
were the case
um there's the temptation of like
leading people into sin because there
are people who are seriously perverted
and so maybe maybe that's an argument
for why you shouldn't just be
having these these naked images in
churches
um i i mean i am definitely a
traditional iconographer so i don't
advocate for the naked people in
churches
but if you look at for example the way
that nakedness is portrayed like
i was trying as we were as we were
talking i was trying to think of other
scenes where the saints are
represented naked and it does it does
happen and it's usually
uh aesthetics like ascetics are
sometimes represented naked yeah
mary of egypt yes saint mary of egypt is
sometimes represented naked
in a way where she's an almost a
skeleton yeah like she's
she's a barely she barely has any flesh
on her
and so there is a way in in which the
nakedness of the aesthetic
is is also this weird place where
scandal and glory
come together you know like you can
imagine when um
saint francis of assisi would disrobe or
ask his his franciscans to
disrobe uh before the in public
like it wasn't it was obviously not to
entice their
entice other people's sexual desire but
it was rather for the person to kind of
descend into that shame of nakedness
in a way that would liberate them from
the
liberate them from that shame in a way
yeah i don't know of that particular
story
um oh that saint francis would disagree
i i've heard stories of you know people
that maybe francis rolling in the snow
or these sorts of things to avoid
temptation but
is it the case that francis asked some
of his brothers to actually strip naked
yeah well francis himself did it and so
francis when francis
kind of uh he started giving his
father's money to
uh right to build a church and then they
brought that's right
he said from now on our father who out
in heaven right and so he took his cl he
this robe then he gave his cloak to to
his father to the priest that was there
and but then he also asked some of his
brothers to do the same at some points
and this probably doesn't mean
undergarments right though i'm sure he's
not like
i don't know i don't cause if that were
the case i mean far be it for me to
criticize a saint but i'd be like that
doesn't seem cool
francis yeah but um i guess i can see
well the holy fools the holy fools are
capable of engaging in this kind of
scandalous behavior uh but they take the
consequences for it but it's also
it is this weird moment like i said
where this strange moment where
the the the nakedness of christ on the
cross is both
the nakedness of scandal and the the
return to the garden
at the same time so i just really want
to understand your argument so forgive
me for
for going back to this is your argument
and maybe you haven't fully thought this
through so i'm not i'm not pressing you
on it or anything
but it seems to be like prior to the
fall one could look upon
another body and and see it in all of
its glory and splendor and without
wanting to use the body
but since the time of we've left the
garden that's no longer
possible and so we shouldn't depict
nudity in
art well i don't think we should depict
it in a sensual
manner at least not at least not in the
church aren't at least not no i agree
but then but i wouldn't consider
like i wouldn't consider the the the
nudity in the sistine chapel to be
sensual in any sense like i agree that
that
those reuben paintings were sensual from
what i saw
um so would you say though that you can
depict
nudity um in a nonsensual way that would
be appropriate
or are you i mean i think people have
done it on the with christ on the cross
forever
and so i mean without necessarily
showing christ's genitalia that christ
is
is basically i would be open to that i
would be open to a beautiful icon
displaying christ genitalia yeah and i
would see i would i would
until this conversation would have
thought that would have been appropriate
or could be appropriate
i don't know i think that i i i'm not
sure i i get the sense that that one
might be
disclosing the disclosing the the the
secret in a way that might not be
appropriate in the public
i would say something say it that way
because he was crucified naked
by all accounts right i think that's
probably he probably was completely
naked
yeah yeah this is this is really
fascinating
feel free to feel free to expand on this
if i'm not giving you enough time to
flesh out your thoughts
but that's what i that's what i think i
think that if you look at the story of
art you'll notice
that when the from the roman period to
the christian period
there was a transformation in the way
that the body was represented
and you can see that there's a use of
all the roman tropes but
transformed into a more sober vision of
the human person
which focuses on the face especially
this encounter with the person right
because you encounter someone
in their eyes and their face and their
expression and so you can see that
that's where the art
towards what the art went and
then during the renaissance which which
i mean this is
this would be a big argument to have but
i think that renaissance is a
is a return to paganism at least for a
little moment uh
during the renaissance then there's this
return to nakedness
uh in in art and also a return to a lot
of the
pagan subjects right you know if you
look at the way that
that michelangelo represents god it's
basically zeus right i mean who is this
figure like
who is this bearded guy like who i'm not
sure who
who is this bearded guy that's touching
adam is it christ
like who is it is it god it's called the
father father it's the father
right yeah so until then like until the
14th century god the father was never
represented in art
interesting you know it's funny it's so
like
very very freak events but it's like
during
all the middle ages the father was never
represented because you don't represent
god
well that's interesting i know what's
interesting is william
craig who i'm sure you're familiar with
yeah he was asked a question about
iconography
you know and i've got my standard
responses right to protestants who tell
me i'm not allowed to kind of depict
things in heaven and earth
um and it was interesting because he
said that he gave one of the responses
i've given right and he said well
you know the second person of the
blessed trinity and becoming man made an
icon of himself
and so he can see an argument for that
but he
he he holds to what you just said that
you shouldn't be making an
icon of god the father but that's
interesting because i'm in trouble if
that is true right because i belong to a
tradition
which does often um depict god in that
way
yeah well less and less and even in the
orthodox in the orthodox tradition
if you look at in starting in the 15th
16th century
there starts to be images of god the
father that are represented at first
they kind of
try to fudge it by representing uh they
call them the the ancient of days and so
they show the ancient of days and then
the the
in the vision of daniel where he gives
his power to the son of man and so they
represent like
christ with white hair and then also
christ as a
as a child on his lap so they try to
fudge it but then that figure of the
ancient of days finally becomes
god the father and they start
representing god the father in
iconography
but now modern iconographers there i
know almost
no modern iconographer that represents
god the father
i i could probably not even count them
on one hand
and what would you say the argument for
that is the argument is
for what you shouldn't still respect the
second commandment
in the sense we under we respect the
notion that you cannot represent god
but through christ because christ is the
image
that god gave to us and so we can see
god in christ but we cannot see god
directly outside of the logos like you
can't see god the father
no like every theophany in the old
testament is is the logos
like we even have this idea for example
that when when god says
i am the one that is it's christ that's
why in the halo of christ
orthodox people would often write the
one that is right
yeah so the one the one who is is
basically saying
you know that vision that moses had
that's what he saw
he saw christ he saw the divine logos
huh i'd have to think more about that
what about when moses sees the back of
god are you saying that's christ too
i mean i would say he hasn't become
incarnate at this point so why does it
matter why do you have to say it's the
sun
well because the sun is the principle of
manifestation of
of the of the trinity right the the
the sun is that by which all things are
made but it's
ultimately also that by which all things
appear right
all the qualities all the names all come
through the sun
and so all categories of existence
are manifested through the sun what does
that mean
all categories of existence what does
that mean
that means that everything that exists
yeah is revealed or manifested through
the sun
okay i don't know what that means
manifested because i'm thinking of john
1 where it says
nothing came to be except through him
that's right but what does that mean
that's a good way
that by him by by so god created the
world
through the divine logo so the the logos
or the
the word is the means by which
god reveals his himself
into creation that makes sense yeah i
think so
say it again so so
so the end of so let's use let's use
secular terms so
so the influence over that episode of
the office where michael scott says
explain this to me like i'm five just
that's kind of what it is
the unbounded infinite that is beyond
all categories totally beyond all name
and
also all comprehension yep all
comprehension
manifests himself through a
concentrating point a son
like his that he engenders and that son
i'm not in secular talk anymore i i i
said i'm going to stay in second talk
and then and then so
then that's how so it's like this you
can imagine the infinite and then
through the logos then the world starts
to manifest the categories
so the difference between christianity
and any other religion
because that idea is there in a lot of
other traditions
but the difference is that we say that
the logos is co-eternal
with the father that we don't think that
the divine logos is created
we think that the divine logos is
uncreated and therefore
the world creation is called to
participate
in god because the way by which it's
made is not
lower than god it's not like a lower
stage than god so when god speaks it's
him
and through his speech then all things
appear
so this idea for example like so
christians could never have this idea
that creation is bad could never have
this idea that
creation in itself is fallen because the
means by which god creates
is god including including the naked
body
including the naked body
in a hierarchy in a hierarchy of being
yeah
yeah no i wasn't i wasn't trying to be a
smart ass i was just saying like that's
true right like
i mean you do have like strands of
christians that
you know speak of the body or speak of
sex or speak of sexual desire in an
anti-body way
well for sure there is there is a strand
of of gnosticism which is
just always there in christianity this
idea
that the world is fallen in itself that
like you said the body is evil in itself
or that sexuality is evil in itself
whereas the the traditional way of
understanding and the right way of
understanding is that
that all things ultimately point to god
if they're in their proper place
it's just about things being in the
right place yes
yeah okay beautiful man all right thank
you i'm gonna have to i have to
listen to my own podcast and think that
through again that was really cool i
appreciate you uh
how do we get we started with
pornography and got to to like talking
about that
well that's a much that's that's uh
that's the way that's the way you want
to go you don't want to start from hard
and go to pornography
um hey i've heard some people say that
icons can be therapeutic not just
therapeutic but kind of healing
they can kind of heal the wound that
pornography has created
i don't know how i feel about that
obviously i think it's a beautiful thing
to stare upon icons but
what would you say to that someone who
says you know i was looking at
pornography it really messed me up and
so to help heal me of that
i just started sitting before icons i
mean i think it's possible i would say
thank god
if that's the case you know or i don't i
wouldn't see it as a formula
like yeah nor would i that's what i'm
having a trouble that's what i'm having
trouble with because i
it sounds really pious but i'm like i
don't see how that could like
just do this and then this will happen i
think that's true i don't think there's
any silver bullet at all you know no
exactly it's like confession yeah and
fight
and pray and fall and get back and pray
and confess and i mean what else like
that's
life you know that's just how it works
yeah
cool all right what else should we talk
about
i don't know what do you want to talk
about i mean
tell me a little bit because i i know a
little bit about you know who are you
talking to like who are the people that
who are you feel is your audience when
you're talking to people
uh who is i i guess i i i think that
catholicism is true
and i want to help people understand the
catholic faith through a sort of
domestic lens i
did my undergrad and masters in
philosophy and a lot of it was domestic
philosophy i love thomas aquinas and
very often on our show we'll kind of
like take a text from the sumer or some
other commentary of his and just sort of
look at it um he's a very clear thinker
he
writes almost syllogistically you know
he
he he steel mans i'm not sure if you've
heard of that term have you yeah yeah
yeah he still meant his opponent's
arguments
and so it's just always interesting you
know like in the summer he'll present
arguments i know you know this but for
those who don't he'll present arguments
against the position he wants to make
and then he'll make his position then
respond to those arguments but then
there are other works of his i have one
over on my shelter it's called day
marlow on evil
where he'll present up to like 20
arguments against the position he wants
to make and then respond to those
and and not in a way that you feel like
he's straw manning the position i
i just find that really intellectually
honest and i know i'm sure i fail at it
but it's something i try to do
as i consider opposing opposing ideas
you know so
yeah i guess you know that's who i speak
to more and more we have
orthodox christians who who are viewing
the channel but i'd say
probably a lot of protestants and a lot
of confused catholics
right who are just we're all going i'm
sure this is true in the orthodox church
churches too right we're all going
through this turbulent time it feels
like
there's this division you know not just
in politics
um but in religions right where you've
got the people who are identifying as
the traditionalists and then the soy
boys
it's probably not what they identify as
but like it's like it feels like this is
splitting apart
every kind of group and i i think
there's just a lot of kind of confusion
and this desire to find something to
anchor themselves to and
that is jesus christ and the scriptures
and
the patristics and the liturgy you know
but yeah
yeah i think that i mean i think it's
wonderful because you're right there is
such a
i think there's such a chaos like we're
we're definitely going through
a period of intense chaos of strange
upside down
things you know happening and and it's
it's infecting the church and it's
everywhere you know it's
for sure i would say in the orthodox uh
church because it's so slow
it's not as prevalent but it's coming
and you can see it coming and you can
see
all the the kind of uh the same type of
conflict that you find
you know in the western christianity are
starting to kind of come into the
orthodox
tradition one question i had for you is
and i know you're a baptist who became
orthodoxy
sometimes i see a lot of vitriol online
from
orthodox people towards catholics and i
don't know if it's like the the kind of
big brother syndrome where you just hate
whatever's bigger than you and
um it's kind of like why new zealand
hates australia but we're like they're
cute they're fine we love them you know
i don't know if there's that thing going
on or but i i suspect there's a lot of
protestant converts who may have had
an anti-catholic sort of bias and
brought that into orthodoxy i'm not
saying there aren't things to critique
in catholicism and if you're orthodox
you you're right to kind of reject what
you believe to be false you know i'm not
saying that makes you anti-catholic or
anything like that
um but yeah i'm just wondering how
that's changing the kind of landscape of
orthodoxy in north america or if you've
noticed that
i think i mean i think that the the
let's say the hostility towards
catholicism that you find in orthodoxy
has a long
story and because like and so because
orthodox are also very slow
slow-moving you know it's like you talk
to orthodox people like they're they're
still living in the fourth century
like to them the arguments that were
happening in the fourth century are
still live
right now yes and so because of that
there really is this sense that the
crusades happened not that long ago
and you know and not just the crusades
but then also the holy roman empire and
the
the you know the kind of taking over of
uh certain orthodox lands
in the modern times so all of that is is
very prevalent in the way
people thinking because eastern europe
is that place where the two
political aspects of the of christianity
just kind of constantly were embattled
and so you
have countries that were orthodox before
they became catholic
and then some that have this weird you
know this and then there's the
kind of like you said eastern catholics
that are kind of in between but they're
not on one side and not on the other
and so because of that i think that's
why you get the hostility
um but
you know i myself i don't i'm not
interested in that stuff i'm just
i don't find it interesting because i
feel like
the world is falling apart to be honest
that so much is happening
that you know i think we can we can
recognize the differences we have
acknowledge the differences but then
also understand that on most fronts
we're on the same side on most fronts of
what's going on in the world
we're on the we're on the same side and
there's also a strange thing
which is happening which is that you
start to notice
for example that the let's say the lines
the battle lines or the the cultural
lines are
going across different christian groups
and so
you end up having people who are serious
about their faith and take it seriously
in their life and in the way they view
the world and want to use their faith as
a lens for
how they perceive reality and you see
that across all different denominations
yeah and then you have people in all the
same denominations
who who desperately want to be accepted
by the world who desperately want
to be progressive and to kind of change
the way that christians understand
things in order to adapt to the modern
world
then you see those also all across the
denominations
so sometimes you end up sometimes i end
up feeling more
sympathy with a catholic or a baptist or
even a pentecostal
who who who takes scripture seriously
who takes christ seriously
then another orthodox who just wants to
be accepted by the u.n or whatever who
just wants to be loved by the
you know by the popular thinking so yeah
that's that's interesting and
you know in in catholicism right now
because we had this big reform right of
the liturgy
um after the second vatican council and
now there's this like desire to return
to our tradition which i'm all in favor
of
and i wonder if there's like an
awkwardness in that you know like
tradition is meant to be this thing
that's passed on that's almost second
nature
it's it's kind of weird when you have to
like grab and artificially impose
upon yourself and your way of life a
tradition that wasn't yours
and maybe that's just what we have to do
until it becomes second nature again
but i think that's one of the most
things catholics love about our orthodox
brothers and sisters that they never had
that same
sort of that same sort of uh
yeah uh change in in the liturgy you
guys have your tradition
and that really feels stable i mean this
has been the line i keep saying like in
a time of chaos you stick you seek
stability if there's a storm outside
you go to wherever feels safest
and and that can that can mean tradition
in a healthy way
but i guess it could also mean a sort of
a kind of
awkward white knuckling sort of um rigid
rigidity
too i mean yeah you id it's it's hard to
find
the balance when the world is kind of
pushing you in a direction and i i i
sympathize for people who kind of
kind of buckle down and kind of hold on
um
but it can be it can be its own idol of
course at the same time if you're not
careful because you
you know we always have to we always
have to remember that christ
both you know both uh would
would criticize the pharisees for
for not embodying the law properly but
then he would also talk to samaritans
and
you know and he would talk to heretics
you know he didn't stop himself
if you understand that samaritans were
heretics at the time of christ
then all of a sudden a lot of a lot of
you can understand the
the possibility of engaging with people
that are
that you feel that don't aren't right on
every point of view you know it
anyway so i i'm not a big i'm not a big
fan of the
hyper traditionalists i find that they
that they kind of
sometimes miss the essential but i'm
also definitely not a fan of the super
progressive yeah
i'm with you yeah i'm with you i'm more
sympathetic to the hyper traditionalists
because i feel like
i can see what they're reaching for yeah
um
and uh yeah man
it's it's crazy hey are you aware of of
these kind of western orthodox folks who
celebrate
one of the western liturgies in but but
who are orthodox
yeah they they always struggle to find
their place like they're
they i think it's an interesting idea
i mean it's probably like me it's
probably like me right who's like
adopting all of these eastern traditions
he goes to
divine liturgy it's it's an awkward
place to be and i heard someone say it's
it's like being the child of divorced
parents you just
feel kind of out of sorts out of place i
think most of the people who are western
orthodox are kind of ex-anglicans
who who kind of have a desire for
anglo-catholicism
uh can't have it in them to let's say
convert to
catholicism yeah and so and so they they
end up becoming orthodox but wanting to
keep their kind of anglo
you know anglo catholic liturgy and
there's also like a weird neo-celtic
uh thing in there like a a kind of idea
of celtic spirituality and
and so what makes that weird because
that sounded pejorative right because
i i kind of feel like if anglicanism
hadn't split from catholicism
the catholicism you would have today
would actually be less roman and more
celtic in an appropriate sense the way
at least that my understanding of the
west the western orthodox
is that they have a sense that the
the let's say the celtic church was
colonized by rome in that
right you know saint augustine uh
actually
imposed the uh the it's in augustine of
canterbury kind of
kind of brought in the latin and kind of
imposed the latin form and
kind of marginalized the celtic
practices and that they're trying to
kind of revive
these these celtic uh practices at least
that's my not everybody it's hard
because it's such a
it's a mess of people like it's it's all
people that are that that are
kind of doing different things but
that's the sense and i it's like i don't
i'm not against it i just i i'm worried
some about things that are kind of
archaeological in their approach where
you know the traditions that are
the traditions that are gone it's hard
to revive them from the outside like you
find these texts you find these old
texts that aren't even
fully there that are missing pages and
they're missing
things and you try to reconstruct the
liturgy of
of like some fifth century celtic saint
it's like
i don't know man it's it's it's maybe
maybe i'm not in i'm not there but i i
think it's better like you said to have
something which is handed down
and which is which has continuity and
what was tough with me and maybe tougher
viewers i didn't have anything handed
down to me like even as
even as a as a western catholic it was
just sort of the
the the nonsense of this you know
secular music being played in church and
you know i wasn't even taught how to
pray the holy rosary we didn't have
incense in church all of that was gotten
rid of because the kids want to be
entertained
anything his father wasn't as funny as
seinfeld and the band wasn't as good as
metallica so he just came across as lame
that but i think that that but that's
it's a good thing right now because i
think that that's one of the things
that's one of the aspects that is
bringing people back to traditional
yeah uh liturgical practice it's that at
some point you realize that
it works for a while to try to carbon
copy the world but
you you run out of breath because you
can never compete with the devil like
you can't compete with
you can't compete with the thing you're
taking it from and so
it ends up it ends up always looking
like a pale
like a pale imitation totally and if
liturgy is the work of the people
then we go to work we we go to we go out
of justice to give god his due to the
degree we can
not to sit back and be entertained yeah
not totally totally too and also because
the forms that we have
are so awesome like the the relationship
between the architecture the liturgy
the images it's like uh it's it's it's
it's this
this this intertextual you know language
of references that will blow your mind
once you start to look at them more
profoundly
and you all of a sudden it's like you
know i always kind of joke with people
that you know
people who like marvel comics or lord of
the rings and
all this stuff where it's like all these
characters that interrelate with each
other and they have crossovers and
everything
like that's what liturgy is that's what
the whole liturgical
cycle is and the relationship between
the architecture and the processions and
all of this
it's it's basically like a giant marvel
comics universe but it's the one you can
live in it's not
it's not something you look at from the
outside you can actually be inside this
intertextual uh
world of relate of references and
relationship and
some parts of this icon appear in this
icon and then you know all of a sudden
you listen to a
hymn and then it says something and you
realize why christ is represented this
way on the cross
there's something in the hymn which is
connecting that and then to the story of
jonah and then to
adam even the it's like it's it's just
this amazing ride you can get on when
you start to see all these references
and how they connect to each other oh
man that's really beautiful
hey what's your opinion on theistic
apologetics because
from from the short discussion we've had
here it sounds like
i don't know it doesn't sound like it
plays a primary role in your christian
life maybe i'm wrong
no not at all okay so why is that and
what's your opinion of it generally
i i don't have a i don't have a problem
with apologetics i think i
i grew up i grew up baptist and i grew
up having at some point you know having
to go
knock on doors and tell people that
jesus loved them and i always
i always promised myself that i would
never evangelize when i became orthodox
i would just never evangelize is that
why orthodox don't evangelize
there is there is no baptist who had to
go knock on doors
but then when i started encountering
atheists
and atheists started writing me and
asking questions and everything all of a
sudden i realized that
there may be another way to evangelize
and it's mostly just talk about how
beautiful this is
and not try to explain it in a way of
defending the positions and everything
but mostly
try to so the way that i talk about
christianity is always
trying to show you how powerful this
pattern is
and how you can live inside it and how
you know you won't find a better story
than the story of jesus
there is no better story like the story
of jesus has
encompasses all strains of storytelling
in
in its story and i can show it to you i
can slowly
point at different aspects of jesus
story and show you how it
how it brings in all these different
elements that you like to watch in
movies
but they're all there they're all
brought together in the story of christ
in a way that
will blow your mind once you start to
see it right so that's mostly been my
approach is just to try to
surprise people with meaning surprise
them with beauty
rather than try to defend this or that
moral position or this or that you know
yeah no and i think you're even though i
think there is absolutely a role for
theistic apologetics because
you know for for a lot of people they're
like it works for some people there are
i mean there are people who are like i
actually want to believe i'm not being
stubborn
i'm not trying not to believe just show
me how this is logical
um but i think you're right and for many
people they've been down that road so
many times and can't kind of make
themself believe
which is interesting because you know
blaise pascal has that answer to those
who want to believe but don't know how
he's like we'll just act like a
christian
like take holy water and say your
prayers and and just do the things
christians do and
see the coherence you know your life
will will adopt maybe maybe that's
more in line with what you're saying
well there's something about
like there's something about the
experience of the liturgy for example
you know if you do if you go in with
like this openness and you this desire
to encounter it and
or the encounter with an icon or the
encounter with a very beautiful
traditional church
that that it goes beyond
the argumentation you know and there's
something about orthodoxy which is just
you've always traditionally been that
you know when they when saint vladimir
uh
of kiev converted to orthodoxy they
always say that it's because
you know they invited his mother to
hagia sophia
and they said here come see what we're
doing and they brought her into the
church and she went through
this magnificent liturgy with huge choir
and you know the
sound reflecting in all these golden
domes and then she went back home and
she said i was in heaven like i just
came back from heaven so
and so i think there's something that is
something in the orthodox tradition
which kind of is conducive to that
it is it's more it's more incarnate
right because if we stick to the kind of
head arguments
what you're saying to your friend when
you invite him to liturgy is like bring
your entire being with you not just your
intellect like in in
experience it and see what happens yeah
yeah and like one of the things i'm
doing for example is
helping people see the story of christ
appear all over and
also the inevitability because one of
the things that people don't realize is
just how christian they are without
knowing it
you know and there are certain tropes
for example in storytelling that are
extremely popular right now or just
inevitable right now that didn't exist
before christ they just didn't
you know the the image of the night for
example
the image of the strong person who
is willing to fight to defend the weak
and to sacrifice themselves for those
who can't fight for themselves that is a
christian story
it's not a there was no none of that in
the pagan world pagan heroes are all
jerks
they're all selfish like boorish uh
people who only care about their honor
whereas the knight
has that idea that you can fight yeah
for the week and so i was just reading
robin hood lately it's my like
bedside story and it's it's exactly that
and so you and so you can't avoid it
like the image or the image of the hero
who gets knocked down and you know kind
of stays down for a while and you feel
he's going to lose and he's going to be
beaten and then he gets back up at the
end
rocking it's such a cliche but without
the resurrection
that story is not it just wouldn't be
part of our
of our uh tropes and so i try to point
to people they say
how much the story of christ has
imbued all our forms and that as we
actually as we move away from
christianity
it even becomes more apparent because we
start to notice now all of a sudden that
every marvel
comic store every marvel movie is about
jesus basically yeah
and it's just in the just little parts
of of jesus's story that are that are
appearing and those well i mean i
watched i watched the first
thor um which i know is kind of based on
mythology anyway but
a lot of them are in some way and that's
just so christian i mean he yeah
he comes to earth he dies and saves us
and resurrects and then ascends
and he and he tells his bride he will be
back for her not his bride but his
girlfriend you know yeah exactly
coming back for a very high number i
think the first thor movie was ken
branagh so he probably was doing it
very very much on purpose but even like
the whole arc like if you look at
the the avengers end game and all that
stuff
that at the end like this i'm going to
spoil them i'm everybody's seen it by
now so
it's your fault if you haven't continued
yeah exactly it's your fault so
i i keep telling people like when so
when
uh at the end the iron man takes the
gauntlet
right and then kills thanos using the
gauntlet
he's making a lord of the rings move
he's taking the ring
and he's using it to fight evil and so
the question is
what's the difference like what's the
difference between why and the lord of
the rings
they can't do that like if they take the
ring they're going to be corrupted by
its power
why is it that that iron man can take
take the ring tony stark and take take
the ring and use it to defeat evil
without
being corrupted and the reason is that
because he sacrificed himself
it's because he died doing it and that's
the only reason why he could do it is
because he knew that he was going to die
when he did that and it's a christian
story it just ends up being a christian
story where
he takes the power of death uses it
against death
to save the world from death but he has
to die himself in order for it to be
legitimate in order for it not to be a
form of
satanic pride he has to die and it's
like
what are you gonna do you can't avoid
the story it's just gonna it keeps
coming back
and back and back yeah trample death by
death
that's beautiful yeah okay cool all
right well hey um
i've loved our chat and thank you so
kindly for
for coming on the show and i hope we get
to chat again um
maybe for those who are watching on my
channel where can they learn more about
you and the great stuff you're involved
in
so i mean you can find my carvings on my
carving website pedro carvings
i'm also on youtube on the symbolic
world where
i talk about uh symbolism in all his
forms i have a website called the
symbolicworld.com as well
where we have a blog and different
people talking about uh symbolism
as it helps you understand the world we
live in and so those are mostly the
places and then you also have a great
teespring account that i'm showing
people right now did you come up with
these designs
are these your products or well not all
there's a few that there's one
at least one or two that i ask someone i
care about that's cosmic mountain one
i'm gonna buy like a hundred of them as
soon as
soon as we're done that's it that's like
the work of that's like the work of 20
years i would say
so i've been thinking about this cosmic
the idea of representing everything in
one image for a very long time
and so finally last year i had the guts
to kind of put it together
oh it's beautiful tell us about it
because it's on the screen for people to
see right now
it's based on the let's say a kind of
bringing together of the story of
genesis with the crucifixion of christ
but also
it joins all different elements of
iconography together in one
image i have a video on my youtube
channel people want to
find out about what what elements that i
drag into this
this this picture but it's also a
description of
uh let's say the the hymns on paradise
vicente from the syrian and uh you know
the the
the scent of the moses of moses on the
mountain in san gorgeous
life of moses so all of the things that
i love about christianity basically
brought into one image just like cosmic
image so it's really terrific and so how
did you do that i mean did you do that
on the computer
was it a carving that you oh it's a
drawing it's a it's a hand it's a hand
drawing yeah oh my goodness dude you're
a very talented man and i'm glad you're
doing what you're doing
thanks thanks for having me it was a lot
of fun i enjoyed it good stuff thanks